سؤال اخر
هو انت وكسر من الزملاء يعني يفكرون
الفلاسفه مثقفون
لديكم اسئله لديكم الهم هم اجتماعي هم
معرفي هم ثقافي
ولكن اريد ان اسال عن سقف الاسئله المتاحه
الان هل من محاذير حول اسئله معينه طبعا
اي انسان
ينتج معرفه يريد ان يقدمها للمجتمع بمعنى
ان يكون فاعلا في المجتمع وجزم الحراكه
الاجتماعي لابد ان يكون ضمن المعادله
الاجتماعيه يعني فهناك دائما محاذير
طبيعيه موجوده لكل مشتغل في اي شيء من
الشؤون المعرفه
لكن اكثر من هذا لا يوجد يعني اكثر من هذا
هناك مساحه واسعه جدا اليوم من التساؤل
الفلسفي يعني هناك اسئله على الموروث او
بعض الموروث اللي اعطنا حركه الفكر
والفلسفه هذا متاح هذا متاح لكن يمكن اللي
صار
مؤخرا انه لم يكن لم تعد هذه هي الوجهه
الوحيده يعني انا اعتقد ان المثقفين بشكل
عام نتيجه الضغط الاصولي جعلوا النقد
الاصوليات اولويه وهذا مفهوم لكن اذا
توفرت هناك بيئه
لا توجد فيها هذه الضغوط على المثقف قد
يعود المثقف مره اخرى الى الاسئله
الاكثر هدوءا احيانا ولكن هي اسئله جميله
هي اسئله فلسفيه اسئله مهمه اسئله تعكس
الشغف يعني احنا نراهن على الشغف الفلسفي
عند الانسان والذي قد يطرح احيانا اسئله
قد تبدو ساذجه قد تبدو
بديهيه لكنها هي هي الجوهر